mais qui es tu disons que je suis le
boss des bosses tu es un bébé tu portes
une couche je sais qui d'autre porte des
couches les astronautes et les pilotes
de course voilà qui emporte s'appelle de
l'efficacité templeton
le bambin moyens pasqua 45 heures par an
minimum sur le pot je suis le porte
j'ai pas de temps à perdre avec ce genre
de trucs
[Musique]
préparer à voir leur famille s'agrandir
suppose sortie on te présente ton but
mais le bébé se préparer à autre chose
nous les bébés on est en pleine crise
les bébés ne reçoivent pas autant
d'amour qu'autrefois
je vous présente notre ennemi mortel le
bébé chien non vous voyez c'est ça le
problème
vous avez appris quelque chose ninon
avez vous des infos sur les bébés chiens
gentils bébé sinon jimbo les bébés
chiens sont démoniaques stacy re lisez
moi vos notes
on sait pas dire qu'est ce que ça dit
bonjour on dirait qu'ils sont à leur
petite table de réunion ghsr
c'est atrocement humiliant je suis le
bébé qui vous font pour ce job je sais
que cette mission est capitale pour la
société messieurs caca prout ans que je
m'occupe du gea est mienne mais je suis
chargé de mission il n'y a pas assez
d'amour pour tout le monde
mon boulot c'est le trouver pourquoi
même chercher un double expresso et
voici à des bons sushis dans le quartier
je tuerai pour un rouleau de ton tataki
au sésame
la guerre est déclarée
gas
dans chaque personne regarde les enfants
ont fini par s'entendre c'est formidable
si je loupe cette mission il faudra que
je vive avec toi pour toujours ou
qu'acheter donne un coup de main mais
seulement si tu fiche le camp après ça
roule
voilà le petit train qui arrive quand il
regarde youtube ok
prends ça dans le tweet your comment on
fait pour passer de baltard
je n'ai jamais connu une telle
humiliation de toute ma vie
[Musique]
je mettrai pas le costume de marin et
inmet pourquoi t'as qu'à la lunette
qu'est ce que c'est tout ce bruit vous
avez vu comme il est mignon
j'en ai apporté aussi quoi paul
dreamworks baby boss pose ce biscuit
tout de suite les biscuits c'est pour
les gagnants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]